GOOD NIGHT.
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
WE DON'T DO A LOT OF WEATHER
SEGMENTS ON THE SHOW BUT WE
COULDN'T HELP NOTICE THIS
PHENOMENON POLAR VORTEX
DESCENDED ON THE AMERICAN
UNITED STATES THIS WEEK.
TEMPERATURES DROPPED TO
TEMPERATURES THAT DIDN'T
SEEM REAL.
38 BELOW ZERO THIS MORNING
NEW STATE RECORD.
IN THIEF RIVER FALLS
MINNESOTA THE TEMPERATURE
APPROACHED 80 BELOW.
COLD LIKE THAT WILL TURN HOT
COFFEE TO ICE CRYSTALS
BEFORE IT HITS THE GROUND.
STAY OUTSIDE FOR ANY LENGTH
OF TIME AND YOU WILL DIE AND
A NUMBER OF PEOPLE DID IN
THAT REGION THEY WERE FOUND
FROZE TO DEATH IN THE LAST
FEW DAYS.
METEOROLOGISTS AND THIS IS
THE GOOD NEWS SAY IT WILL
WARM UP SOON.
CLIMATE CHANGE WILL CONTINUE
AS IT ALWAYS HAS.
SPRING WILL COME.
BUT THIS IS A GOOD REMINDER
OF SOMETHING.
ENERGY MATTERS.
IT KEEPS US ALIVE.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF YOU
DIDN'T HAVE ENERGY?
THAT'S SOMETHING WE MAYBE
NEED TO CONSIDER VERY SOON
BECAUSE OF SOMETHING CALLED
THE GREEN NEW DEAL.
WHAT IS THAT?
IT'S NOT CLEAR.
TAKE A LOOK NOW AT A
DESCRIPTION BY THE CHIEF
PROPONENT OF THE GREEN NEW
DEAL.
WATCH.
>> YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
ZERO CARBON EMISSIONS, NO
USE OF FOSSIL FUELS WITHIN
12 YEARS?
>> THAT IS THE GOAL.
IT'S AMBITIOUS.
>> HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE?
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
EVERYBODY HAVING TO DRIVE AN
ELECTRIC CAR?
>> IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE A
LOT OF RAPID CHANGE THAT WE
DON'T EVEN CONCEIVE AS
POSSIBLE RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: SO NO FOSSIL
FUELS WITHIN 12 YEARS.
THERE'S A LOT WE DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THIS PLAN BUT THAT
WOULD DEFINITELY BE THE
HEADLINE.
THEY SPELLED IT OUT VERY
CLEARLY.
BEFORE WE CAN ASSESS WHETHER
GETTING TO THAT POINT NO
FOSSIL FUELS IN 12 YEARS IS
EVEN POSSIBLE, IT IS AS THE
CONGRESSWOMAN JUST SAID AN
AMBITIOUS GOAL, LET'S
CONSIDER WHAT IT WOULD MEAN
FOR THE UNITED STATES.
NO FOSSIL FUELS WOULD MEAN
NO COAL, NO OIL, NO NATURAL
GAS.
AND THAT WOULD MEAN NO CARS
AND NO AIRPLANES.
IT WOULD MEAN SHUTTING DOWN
THE SINGLE MOST VIBRANT PART
OF THE U.S. ECONOMY WHICH IS
THE ENERGY SOMETHING TORE.
IT WOULD MEAN PUTTING AT
LEAST 6 MILLION AMERICANS
OUT OF WORK IMMEDIATELY.
AS OF TODAY, AMERICA IS THE
LARGEST OIL PRODUCER IN THE
WORLD.
THE COUNTRY EXPORTS MORE
NATURAL GAS THAN ANY OTHER
PLACE.
MORE THAN 90% OF ALL OF OUR
ENERGY COMES FROM FOSSIL
FUELS AND NUCLEAR POWER WE
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
REPLACE THAT IN 12 YEARS
USING PRIMARILY SOLAR AND
WIND POWER.
AMBITIOUS?
THAT'S ONE WAY TO DESCRIBE
IT MORE DESTRUCTIVE THAN A
MAJOR WAR ON U.S. SOIL WOULD
BE ANOTHER WAY TO DESCRIBE
IT SENATOR KIRSTEN
GILLIBRAND CALLING THE
PROSPECT OF THIS A REALLY
EXCITING THINGS.
DAM LA HARRIS AGREES.
BERNIE SANDERS ISN'T SIMPLY
A FAN HE SAYS ELIMINATING
FOSSIL FUELS IMMEDIATELY IS
A MORAL IMPERATIVE.
>> THAT IT IS ABSOLUTELY
IMPERATIVE AND A LIFE AND
DEATH DEATH ISSUE THAT WE
HAVE TO TRANSFORM OUR ENERGY
SYSTEM AWAY FROM FOSSIL FUEL
TO SUSTAINABLE ENERGY.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: WHAT'S SO
INTERESTING ABOUT THAT IS
THAT THE PARTY OF SCIENCE
SOMEHOW FORGOT TO CONSULT
ACTUAL SCIENTISTS ABOUT
THEIR PLAN.
TALK TO SOMEONE WHO STUDIES
ENERGY AND SEE FOR YOURSELF.
WE ARE NOWHERE NEAR BEING
ABLE TO DO ANY OF THIS.
WIND POWER IS A SCAM.
IT'S AN ELABORATE RIP OFF
PERPETUATED ON IMPOVERISHED
RURAL AMERICA BY GETTING
IRISH MAKING THE LANDSCAPE
UGLIER.
SOLAR IS A PROMISING
TECHNOLOGY ACTUALLY BUT SO
FAR BEING ABLE FROM BEING
ABLE TO EFFICIENTLY STORE
THE ENERGY IT PRODUCES AND
STORAGE IS KEY IN A POWER
GRID.
SOLAR IS NOT A REPLACEMENT
FOR FOSSIL FUELS NOW OR ANY
TIME SOON.
ANYONE WHO TELLS YOU
OTHERWISE HASN'T BOTHERED TO
LEARN ANYTHING ABOUT IT THAT
WOULD BE DESCRIBE MOST OF
THE PEOPLE PUSHING THE NEW
DEAL.
HOW IS WIND POWER GOING TO
HEAT YOUR HOUSE WHEN IT'S 30
BELOW.
WHAT IS THE RANGE EXACTLY ON